live streaming has been an interesting
experience
and i'm recording this video while
driving which i know some of you guys
rage about
but as you can see i'm keeping my eyes
on the road
and i've got the pause button ready
right here and i'm i'm on an automatic
not a stick shift we're good don't you
worry eyes on the road
so now with that out of the way um
i just want to say and explain to some
people because i don't think they quite
understand or realize
the streaming's kind of stressful
and it doesn't really pay anything
except for
you know the top streamers which is who
everybody watches and who everybody
hears the opinion of
and they kind of you know just get the
base understanding that if you do this
regularly you're making thousands
tens of thousands of dollars per stream
which is not the case
i tend to make about
30 to 40 cents
yes you heard that right somewhere
around a quarter maybe a little bit more
maybe a little bit less per stream and
it doesn't even really matter how long i
stream
i've streamed for two hours and made
that much i've streamed for 11 hours and
made that much
so
i'm not exactly getting paid to do this
the power
and internet cost more than i make
streaming and this is true for pretty
much all small streamers well
uh
most are bigger than me i'm still really
small
okay so i'm getting to on my next point
here
and that is
the people who come in to chat
some of them are cool some of them are
fine some of them are friendly
they get it
but then there are others that drop by
that are completely oblivious
and these are the ones that kind of
drive me a little crazy
so the other day when i was streaming
someone popped in
and said hi so i said hi back
that that's that's a nice simple
starting interaction
and then this person took that as an
opportunity
all right let me let me back up a little
bit first here i was working on
creating unit tests for my game engine
just sitting there building unit tests
working
obviously on my own project
uh no indication that i wanted to see
other people's projects and review
projects it wasn't that kind of day it
was a work day
this person just decides to drop in
and then start spoon
their findings and their findings their
project they said hey i i don't know
they made a really really long paragraph
it was absurdly long i didn't even read
at all it was that long yeah but it was
something about cryptocurrency
sounded like some kind of scam at first
but then as i got a little further they
were writing some sort of app that dealt
with cryptocurrency and
something about is it going to be
uh i think the number they projected was
uh
1 000
faster
not 100
would it be a thousand percent faster
than c plus plus
and as soon as i saw that number i was
like okay i'm not diving into this
wormhole of nonsense whatever this guy's
talking about i don't even care anymore
and uh then they proceeded to follow up
with here's a link to the project
something about could you review it
and uh
well i was like i'm i'm working here man
you see the title
so i was thinking so i was like all
right i'll give them the benefit of the
doubt did they like leave me a tip or a
sub before you know
just dumping this on me
and i look
no sub
no no tip or donation
just uh not even a follow not even a
follow
just uh
just dropping into a random streamer oh
you got you don't have very many viewers
you must be wanting
uh a bunch of additional work just
dumped on you
that that sounds legit well you might
you mind just checking this out and
reviewing it and give me some tips all
for the low price of
free
um in the middle of your current work
not one of your streams where you're
asking to review stuff just just in the
middle of your current work
uh i see that you're busy you mind just
eating this
big giant chunk of work for me
pretty rude pretty rude so
uh
i
i banned them
that was that was pretty much it and i i
told them what i told you i said look uh
i'm not getting into that can of worms
and i was like um
are you a sub are you a follower and i
looked nope no
and i said here's what i'll do for you
band
and then i said something along the
lines of have some common courtesy
um
yeah so that's pretty much my experience
with streaming sometimes
uh just i i don't i don't even get it
i like the social aspect of it i like
saying hi to people i like meeting other
people some of that's kind of cool
but like when people come in and just
want to like dump work on you and expect
you to do it for free
what man
all right that's it just kind of wanted
to make people aware that uh
i stream
and uh
just because i'm a small streamer
doesn't mean i'm gonna take your crap
so
be cool or get banned